[Music]
welcome everybody
service in real life okay studying the
trophy industry we are very much aware
that we're probably did last session it
you're gonna do today so we can either
decide to drag it along or rush it
through it but we'll see how how will
you respond to our jokes so alright
alright well I'm James Daniels I'm an
SDK engineer on the firebase team and
Here I am in the pictures I had a little
bit more facial hair there but as you
can see we're very serious people yeah
and to make sure we added the arrow so
that you don't confuse them for the
pineapple and sorry
my name is the staff and over nine I'm
the chief geek and CTO at cloud er cloud
or CCS and I'm also a Google developer
expert for Google cloud platform and
firebase and yes there's arrows pointing
to me as well because some people might
mistake me for a pineapple
anyways so imagine that you want to go
on a trip of a lifetime for most
Europeans that probably means going
through Australia New Zealand anybody
from Australia or New Zealand just
imagine that everything that we say
about your country basically applies to
you going to Europe or whatever extra
like destination that you want to go to
but just imagine that you want to go
that you want to go on a trip of a
lifetime we have a customer that has a
lot of a lot of consumers or customers
that really have that dream and that
dream that one that once in a lifetime
Oh take me to that wonderful place and
provide me with that vacation of a
lifetime and so they're really as they
say they're in the industry of making
dreams come true their specialized in in
Australia New Zealand travels that's why
I mentioned if you're from those areas
just imagine that we're doing the other
way around and just keep in mind it's
pretty cool but it's not as cool as your
country although we don't have stuff
that tries to kill you New Zealand
that's where the hobbits are from right
absolutely
I need to I need to go yeah I'm not sure
if I was trying to try and kill you as
well but I might have to rewatch the
movie anyways so now I imagine it you
have to make those stream those dreams
come true
he's quite a bit of systems and staff
today it's not like they're organizing
vacations for like one family it's quite
a few families that are trying to do it
so they need quite a bit of systems
quite a bit of staff to do they need to
scale up because they're doing a pretty
good job at what they do they've got the
radio commercials going on there now in
different different countries in Europe
they're really scaling and that kind of
brings brings all the challenges as well
and so that that's it makes it a bit
more difficult to you know make dreams
come true
so without diving into those dreams and
all the architecture and all that let's
first try and see how we got started
with discuss turin and how we introduced
me into service funny story
the CEO and the CEO of traffic license
called Andrew Morton he always tells us
that hey we're always looking to enhance
just to enhance our systems to it so
that we can ensure that the people that
are in our company actually speak to
people because if you make dreams come
true well we're all most of us are have
some engineering background so for us
it's probably dreams coming true by
speaking to computers but if you're in
the travel industry it usually means
that you want to speak to other people
that actually tell you where it's cool
and where you need to go so yes that's
what their purpose is speak to people
deal with people now if you're dealing
with people that's it's pretty cool but
just imagine that you're that your
customer of theirs and you're talking to
an agent and you're talking about your
vacation and the first thing that the
agent goes like oh yeah by the way can
you tell me you're at itinerary number
or your customer number you know if
you're doing a triple for lifetime you
want to feel special you don't want the
agents going so you know it's kind of
boring or annoying and then you might
have somebody else in your party or any
family joining you and sending them
emails and saying oh yeah I know that
we're going to somewhere in somewhere in
Australia but can we also go to that
other place and oh can we also see you
know more animals Achilles and then the
agent goes like who are you and then
somebody else from your from your party
also goes like oh yeah and I want to go
there and can you tell me a bit more
about this and that so before you know
it
either you I did a customer T agent will
go like what I mean what am i doing why
I make who are these people or if you're
the customer like why don't they
understand who I am and why don't they
make my dream come true so that kind of
kind of its gonna annoy me I guess yeah
so what they all say is first thing to
do is you know can you get and can't
help us and get a grip of the
communications that we have with a
customer so fortunately the customer
tough license was already on G suite so
what we did is we took the email via API
for 4G Suite ran a little program on App
Engine that would extract emails from
from the environment we would then feed
those emails through the natural
language processing API applied some
other stuff as well obviously you can do
regular expressions and all that to
identity sea travel surf IDs and some
other stuff that we that you can do
programmatically but we also needed to
be able to interpret what was in the
emails and really trying to understand
who this relates to or or to what
travels or what truffle parties the
emails related to so we used the NLP API
with some with some with some extra
secret sauce we then took all that
information put it back in bigquery and
made sure that this stuff really had a
better view and a better understanding
of who they were talking to now when we
delivered that the customer went like oh
this is great this is this is this is
pretty cool
now tell us what servers that we need to
install this on and we like well you
don't so the customer like okay then
where does it run and we have to explain
to them a service so the cool thing is
we can now say hey look Francis no
service so doing serve lists or doing
the surface it's not something that we
did accidentally like oh hey let's try
it is but it is part of the philosophy
that we have as a company that when you
when you try and build a solution the
first thing that you do is you try and
do this surplice you start with service
because if you start with service one of
the one of the very nice things about it
is that you can more or less only focus
on the functionality that you try and
deliver and we've been doing this for
for like ages I've been I'm
self have been doing a pension since
what eleven years so and that was for me
like the first step or the first the
first item that that I recognized as as
being surplice and that's why for
service I used the app engine I can
James had some objections but hey once
again the cool thing is you just focus
on the functionality now it might
sometimes be that you try and run
something on servos in it or you want to
do something on service and it just
doesn't work on surface yeah you need to
use that one specific API or the
customer wants you to use that one
specific library and it just doesn't
that just doesn't run on service because
of the language because the time it
takes and things like so what we then do
is we look at containers we look at
container engine and things I and run
our code there and if we really can't
run it in in containers we'll go to
we'll go to VMs and then try and fix it
on PM's if it doesn't get if it doesn't
work there yeah we're not gonna run it
on an ace 400 or something so we're just
trying to redesign it the cool thing is
that if you take this approach you you
always know most of the time you end up
with an application as a surface and
once again you can focus on the
functionality and also the cool part is
that if you start from the other end in
which virtual machines you'll hardly
ever make it into service so that's it's
a nice thing to know as well now I'm
very passionate about service I'm so
passionate and I even have like a very
crude statement here if you're offended
by that cool my statement is that if
you're not building service you're
robbing your customers of innovation
because what you end up doing is you'll
end up providing your customers a whole
bunch of epidural and whether your
customer is an internal customer or it's
an external customer because you're like
a Google porn like we are but if you if
you don't do service you're robbing them
of innovation because you ask them to
spend a lot of time on maintaining
systems understanding technology and all
the customer really wants you to do is
focus on functionality because deaths
where the cool stuff is quoting yourself
as a real power move thought leader I
know I know
thank you for that so what we do weird
so to put it in into context this was
the the landscape that the customer was
looking at so coming back from a or
doing something service was kind of new
to them at least they felt like that but
they already had some stuff in the in
the cloud so they were using GG sweeeeet
they had a financial application that
they weren't running in the cloud but
the primary systems that the stuff that
really makes their organization what it
is and enables them to sell to create
for you those those magical the travels
that's really all about legacy systems
so they had a legacy itenary system they
ran an mi sequel fortunately they had
they had a bit of an insight and putting
that on con sequel but that was like the
only service thing that did they had PHP
application logic running on some
servers they had third party API calls
running on servers and a lot of that so
it was really a legacy infrastructure
now what we did because we showed him
that we could do stuff service and we
could really focus on the under
functionality there also like hey can
you help us and maybe replace some of
some of our outdated legacy features and
replace that with new us with new
features and new applications and maybe
run that under on that service stuff as
well so that's what we started doing we
hooked up once again App Engine our
faithful workhorse and hooked it up into
their legacy IT system started getting
data out of that and then putting that
into into five easily into into fine
store the reason for that is because it
was easy it has you it is fairly easy
API and yeah you case you guessed it
it's service so and it really allows us
to build basically in an anterior
application so if you look at that
architecture right this is that modern
three-tier architecture right this is
something that we're aiming to achieve
especially for those customers that
we're trying to migrate into the cloud
right so we have these three tiers this
great academic separation of concerns
right we have our presentation layer
with our orchestration gateways CDN and
then our clients also on that side
they'll fit in that bucket we then have
our application logic or code servers
hopefully on the cloud but they probably
have stuff also still on Prem and this
is also where they the layer which they
call out to third parties and then of
course the great data tier and your DBA
is manage this and it's sacred and no
one touches the database without
permission right so this also fits this
model right so you have your app you're
talking to the compute serverless
hopefully you're doing that through you
know load balancers and proxies and then
that compute to Xen you know it's an a
trusted environment and it has
administrative access to your database
it's talking to say a cloud firestore as
someone on the firebase team I'm a
little biased but I think firestore is a
very awesome
no sequel database and gives you some
strong guarantees which are very cool so
once we get into fire store one of the
cool things here is actually fire store
is an event emitter within Google Cloud
so rights to fire store are an event
matter they can actually be monitored by
cloud functions you can also monitor
cloud storage buckets if you're using
firebase authentication or CICP you can
monitor user creation events stuff like
that
and when this event happens when this
event is sourced it can actually fire up
a cloud function and cloud function I'm
JavaScript developer so I write nodejs
scripts there
so I write node code and the function
executes this is a serverless
infrastructure net spin ZUP these
workers on demand to fulfill these event
sources and if you imagine this cloud
function could then start writing back
to fire store right so you write data in
one part of the database there's maybe a
mutation a side-effect it calls a third
party API another GCP product and it
takes that results and
does stuff with it and writes it back
into fire store and then you know the
next time the application like reloads
the data or something like that the
server fetches it you have all the
caching and you know typical stuff but
it's starting to get reactive on that
back end now we can take this a step
further right now that we're farming
that logic out to reactive responses to
the database writes my own would take it
that step further we no longer need that
application server so this is where we
can start you know testing the wire
waters on this native fire store
architecture right so the client-side
application whether it be an iPhone
Android or web application directly
communicates it's a fire store no
intermediary servers no load balancers
it sends its data writes and reads
directly to the database and when any
mutations happen a cloud function can
trip trigger and then right back to fire
store and the cool thing about this is
you get the super powers of firebase
right so you have a cloud function
respond to this event it changes
something in the database and the client
is listening right with firebase when
you make a query to the database it can
be but by default it's not a one-time
operation right you're listening to
snapshots so you query and it actually
creates a persistent socket to the
database so when the data and the
database changes the client gets at in
real-time all the other clients
listening to that point in the database
get those streams in real time ten
hundred milliseconds somewhere around
there and it creates this magical
real-time experience where you no longer
have this pull-to-refresh model that you
see in a lot of applications
another benefits of going down this path
and using the firebase SDKs to access
your data is that we've actually written
offline capabilities into the
application you don't have to do
anything so I showed that very academic
three-tiered web architecture and
there's a lie there right that clean
separation of concerns breaks down when
your application hits production so that
database tier maybe you need to make it
more performant so you add a Redis and
start cashing things and well now you
have a database at the application level
layer and then you need offline
capability so you add sequel lights or
local storage for web applications and
now again you have data on the
presentation tier and you need to worry
about keeping those in sync and
contention and you know detecting online
versus offline and that's a lot of work
a lot of code and a lot of places where
that theoretical separation of concerns
breaks down and get bugs fortunately
we've done that work for you and
ultimately this empowers your developers
to focus on the business logic of your
application build things and ship things
faster and hopefully have a smaller
office team so what power is this right
is breaking down this wall the idea is
that your data data storage data access
you know pushing things to the database
reading things out it matters to every
one of these tiers right the application
the presentation and of course the data
layer so the access is is co-equal
between all these and then you get that
the firebase SDK and the tight
integrations with Google Analytics and
the firebase authentication and then of
course cloud functions to respond as
side effects we jokingly call it side
effects as a service on the team and
ultimately you know when you write
they do operations right back and that
streams to the client creating this
magical experience
now this is where I'll talk to a lot of
developers that are used to doing things
through load balancers and API servers
and I start saying interact directly
with the database the production
database interact directly with it from
your client-side application and I
always get this little horrified look
and I know what's coming and they're
saying how can this be secured at all
right I'm just giving out the keys to my
database to any iPhone app everyone who
visits my website and the key here is
this integration with firebase
authentication and our security rules
product so with security rules you can
actually write rules that limit the
operations on any path in your database
any document to some sort of condition
and you can look at the user doing that
the keys associated with them and you
can even look in other places in the
database and make sure oh they have
permission to this in that all right so
what we really have but what you're
basically saying is that for us doing a
service thing was like one servlet step
for us it's a giant leap in architecture
pretty awesome yes I quoted somebody
else so what is nice is that you really
put that that native firestorm on oh
yeah I should describe it it really
works for us and it kind of took takes
away the complexity that we might
otherwise have you know creating
creating a REST API on our database and
having to go through all those motions
and service and add and and and things
like so really the App Engine that we
have or the App Engine application that
we have in the application is now only
service service doing some work to get
data out of the out of the legacy system
so that's pretty awesome so we can
actually start to make the application a
bit simpler and then by having the
client directly connecting with the
woodfire store or with firebase we have
that that interaction and we allow the
users because we have that connection
the native
connection it allows us to build an
application where if users are working
on an itinerary together and that
happens because somebody might be
booking a hotel somebody else might be
booking a car or some event that people
might want to go to you actually see the
updates appear on your screen straight
away and that actually saves our our
customer or did the agents at our
customer quite a bit of time and it
allows them to better interact with the
system but also if they're on the phone
with the customer be sure that they have
those real time and real life updates no
matter what the system is doing even if
the system in the background is booking
airplane tickets or whatever they get
the latest information and that's really
awesome so it allows us to do to do a
bit more volume handling of itinerary
events it doesn't cause all sorts of
telescas motions where people have to do
all sorts of stink all sorts of extra
things like hit extra buttons or
actually actually do actual work it
really helps the customer to focus on
what is important in functionality and
for us it also helps us to focus on what
the customer really finds important does
it you might have noticed that there's a
theme here now you know if we're talking
about one of the very nice things is
that we're we're not using functions to
handle all sorts of things and the
customer is actually quite quite happy
with app and we're we're looking into
you know getting some of the other
systems that are integrating with it and
and get that going as well so they've
got the financial system so hey why not
you know use firebase cloud functions or
use cloud functions to actually start
writing information back into the
financial system or maybe do some office
of flight bookings by the way the
finance system is actually pretty cool
because it has a pretty good REST API
the car rental system because most of
the time when you know Australian New
Zealand you want to drive around and
things like that that that has pretty
cool API as well it's just hope API is
no schools the REST API but hey still
pretty good flight booking system that
was a bit more a bit more difficult it's
a bit more traditional but hey we can't
deal with that you know functions are
cool we can do everything with that
excellent so you know we didn't might
hit a snag way we might need to use some
of that container stuff that I talked
early about so we do everything service
if we come to service will hit
containers it goes in the other external
store
some of the things that they want to do
because as you can imagine travel
expensive and a u.s. travel agency might
have to make payments due to eight it to
to hotels and things like front so they
have some some fun hedging that they do
and the cool thing is that the bank that
they're doing that with is very it
phones and sends them in a PDF once in a
while that says all you add the exchange
rates for today for the for the
Australian dollar didn't what is it New
Zealand dollar is this in that and we
have to get that from the from the PDF
that's not too bad now now it sounds
like you know you're you've touched on a
couple points here like functions is
great I love functions it has a tight
integration with firebase but you know
you mentioned container engine maybe
some harder workloads you put through
that because functions has a timeout and
that's not really meant for that but you
know I'm concerned about some of these
other api's too so you know I threw
functions at you but let's talk a little
bit about functions and how they're
designed and the workloads that they
support so first and foremost functions
is at least once right
cloud functions are designed to reliably
definitely do something when you have a
right to your database when a files
uploaded you really want that job to
occur now I'm not a theoretical computer
scientist I wasn't that diligent in
school but I work with a bunch of them
and from my understanding with
distributed systems having you know
anything less than at least once maybe
exactly once has a very hard problem to
do within a distributed system so maybe
you have a network partition show up
these workers are now out of sync and
they can't tell if they're doing each
other's jobs
so cloud functions to ensure that a job
occurs will trigger more than once right
maybe you get duplicate fires so one of
the things that we always tell people is
make sure the side effects and cloud
functions
our idempotent so they're also designed
for on-demand provisioning right these
servers go from 0 to infinity right
they'll scale to meet your workload and
the data enter they're entering the
system but cloud functions is designed
for database rights and storage uploads
and and end-user things basically right
so a user clicks a button or uploads a
file and these kind of you know maybe
they batch and maybe it gets you have
busy parts of the day but ultimately
these are kind of random events and not
very predictable otherwise and they're
designed for immediate fulfillment since
these are for end-user response when a
result comes into the system when an
action happens we want the side effect
to happen as quickly as possible right
maybe one of the the functions is busy
we don't want to interrupt that we don't
want to limit us resources so cloud
functions the concurrency per worker is
one we give it that job the full
resources of the container so if you
have a bunch of events coming in it has
to spin up new functions and you can
have if you imagine if you eat a huge
burst of activity maybe you'll have a
bit of a backlog and the idea there is
just to get it done as quickly as
possible
and respond to those so going back to
this case right
you know if you've worked with stripe or
some of the modern payment providers
they're great because they're cloud
native api's and they have idempotency
tokens so you could use your firebase
event ID or your document ID to make
sure that you don't double bill a client
we're talking legacy api's they're
probably more meant for this
transactional centralized world so
without an idempotency token we double
bill your customers right not good not
good
maybe this flight booking API as a
traditional API but you know very big
enterprise so maybe there's really harsh
quotas on that right I'm not allowed to
their API more than once every 30
seconds because they don't want people
gaming the system so if we have a lot of
events coming at once we could get
throttled or banned which is not a good
experience for our users
this soap API right maybe again quotas
but it being soap maybe they're
expecting batch data right they're
saying don't hit our API more than once
every 15 seconds but feel free to batch
a bunch of requests and one cloud
functions is it really suited for that
it's immediate action
it's stateless right it's not gonna fit
well in this world and then you know you
mentioned the other sources these PDFs
getting sent to you from the bank then
include the you know the the conversion
rate between currencies like that's a
lot of data container engines definitely
good there but I imagine that that could
be rapid-fire right you're getting when
currencies fluctuate they fluctuate
rapidly you'll get a lot of events from
the system all at once and you know
again that that stepping function where
things spin up not necessarily great for
this use case so now you're backing
things up and your back end yeah I'm
starting to feel a bit like your emojis
like you know it's I was quite happy I'm
like oh yeah we're gonna do it do talk
about server listen I am really cool and
you basically know it tells me that I'm
not that cool well the cool thing is now
by the way that for the Dutch people
you'll recognize this as Dells blob or
Delft blue for the Dutch about people
just look it up on the Internet
you'll get it but you know I noticed
this this is a whole bunch of products
that Google has but you know we like our
cloud functions and so so cloud
functions do tie in great with firebase
right there are native events or sing
but there are a lot of products so eeny
meeny miny moe aha dataflow
so cloud dataflow is a
streaming processing engine right it's
meant to take either batches of data or
large streams of data and handle them in
a functional model so I'm a functional
programming nerd so I really like this
product it's fully managed and no ops so
it does take your box of serverless the
provisioner is centralized but the
workers are decentralized serverless
that can spin them up and because it's
meant for event sources it can be a
little bit smarter about provisioning
and it's based off the open source beam
model so comparing it to cloud functions
right I mentioned cloud functions is at
least once you can have double fires now
cloud dataflow
how this differs is the events that come
into cloud dataflow our first pass
through a bloom filter so it's gonna
filter out those duplicates and then
when it spins up the workers you have
deduplicated data so because this is
exactly once you can safely handle side
effects without the need of figuring out
idempotency cool so we can just book
that flight once instead of sending the
family Jones like six times on the same
flight yeah yeah you would not want to
when a network shard appears bill your
customer for six tickets to Australia
it's a little place all right so this is
adding to the dream hmm
so with cloud functions you have this
on-demand provisioning right this is
meant for sort of random user generated
events and it's sort of a stepper
function right it'll go do I have enough
workers to fulfill this maybe I'll spin
up a new one as load increases and then
they'll slowly spin down whereas data
flow coming from data processing
pipeline an ETL pipeline tool it's gonna
have more predictable scaling it can
actually look at the inflow and the
outflow of the system how long the jobs
are taking the error rates and it can
calculate the number of workers it needs
and it's a highly
model so it's gonna be able to get those
jobs done as quickly as possible well
also balancing cost for you cool so we
really get a predictable pipeline no
backlogs and all that and the customer
really gets to well I almost I have like
a certain reassurance in time in
delivery or execution of actions without
having to spend like a ton of money on
it
cool yeah more predictable cost
definitely and then cloud functions is
designed for this immediate as quick as
possible I'll spin up new servers if
need be
fulfillment right where as data flow
being for data batching and processing
and this functional programming motto
I can run filters on my code I can group
them I can sort them I can do windows so
I can say batch this data by you know
five minute increments or give me a
sliding 10-minute window and that way we
can be a lot more intelligent in the
data that we take and we put into our
stores and processing the rest of the
system so that we don't overwhelm our
system excellent and that really helps
us with you know dealing with the car
API where we can only do so many
requests per time I returned unit batch
those things yeah we'll get a little
this kind of that wonderful and and also
those PDFs from the bank right those the
interchanges and the the currency
transfer rates are gonna change rapidly
and if you're working with something
like firestore there's a quota right so
there are max rates at which you can
mutate your data over time so like in
firestore you can't write to a document
at a sustained rate more than once per
minute so now extrapolating that into
this this architecture that we that we
wrote out so now we have cloud functions
and we're actually going to pipe this
data to cloud pub/sub
because cloud pub/sub is the system that
works really well with data flow so it
can actually ingest events from that
that's a stream processing capabilities
where as cloud functions is tightly
integrated into the the firestore event
sources so we just pipe that along now
data flow can do any batching it can do
any filtering sorting and it can also do
these side-effects that you know might
be legacy systems from their outputs the
data to pub/sub again and then we can
actually have the cool thing about
pub/sub is we can have multiple
subscribers to a pubsub stream so we can
have two different cloud functions one
listening to the pubsub stream and
writing back to firestore and then one
listening to the pubsub stream and
writing any relevant information we want
back to bigquery so that way if either
one of these has load problems or errors
they're not gonna affect the other cool
thanks
all right to be honest I was kind of
joking with oh man our presentation is
going to pieces because we did it wrong
no customers were heard grading the
system this is actually the architecture
that we deliver it it has it we took
care of all the and we took care of the
idempotency we took care of the the
batching we took care of all the stuff
that we needed to do to make a really
scalable and reliable system for this
customer and what is what is well sort
of funny it depending if you if you were
the IT guy probably not but since they
are in business of selling selling
travel and they're selling dreams and
they're not in the business of selling
IT or creating ITC
running IT systems what they actually
did is they were using the system
they're not able to serve more customers
without having even with even less IT
people running them it's actually quite
extreme the number of IT people that
they have is exactly zero so that's the
IT guy by the way got in great new
position somewhere else and we're we're
working with him very closely on that
but the really nice thing is it really
helps us and it really helped a customer
create
a solution in which they can run their
business and they can run their business
at scale because as I said before
they're not doing this for it from one
or two customers they're doing quite
quite a few million euros per year
selling selling truffle so now with all
this with all this in place we now have
a very strong a very structured
environment that we can use and maybe
it's time to also look at some of the
future developments that were that we're
seeing that we can do so just to kind of
reiterate where we're coming from so we
helped the initial customer question was
hey help us communicate and we used that
to interview service to them we then
started adding more complex workloads to
their environment or taking care of some
of the more complex workloads they had
in their legacy system and move them
into a service environment we integrated
with some of the legacy systems they had
and we really made the system more
robust so that it could handle a higher
volume of traffic now with that in place
one of the few one of the future steps
that we're gonna take is obviously
connect to the consumer so connect to
their customer and make sure that a
customer that customer has an even
better experience after the booking
process and what we also do is we're
gonna optimize the systems as we go
along because one of the really cool
things about a Google cloud platform and
the service operations that we use is
that there's a constant change in the
constant update of those two of those
technologies ever increasing and ever
allowing for better integrations and
better optimizations of code and better
developer work streams as well so one of
the things one of the things that we're
gonna do
up next is we're going to optimize the
container based development workflow so
right now the forget for the developers
did the container workflow was slightly
different their container development
workflow was slightly different from the
service workflow where you're just
creating your cloud functions and all
that doing doing the containers was a
bit more difficult and with the
announcement of a Google cloud run that
was that was made this morning we'll be
able to kind of align the development
process of the developers when they it
has to do the containers align that a
bit better with the development
workflows that they have using cloud run
yeah and definitely cloud runs really
cool technology
if you haven't gone through any sessions
today do sit in the keynotes tomorrow
and you know there's gonna be plenty of
sessions coming up about this container
definitely definitely check it out and
also and I he can't say it but I can
because he's under NDA and I'm well I'm
sort of as well but there's a lot of
cool stuff coming coming up in the in fi
base a realm as well that will really
help people doing service application
development we're not even in only in
the firebase realm but also in the beer
Google cloud realm with some of it with
a lot of cool stuff that they'll they'll
be announcing over the next days and
some of the stuff at i/o as well so I'm
really looking forward to that one of
the other things that we're gonna do is
we're gonna optimize insights and be
more predictive on the workloads so
obviously we have some prediction and we
have optimized workloads coming from
from data flow but they also have their
own workflows and their own data loads
that we need to do with and as you might
have seen in the image before that we're
writing a lot of the information or a
lot of the process information we're
writing that back to to bigquery now the
reason why we're doing that is because
it will allow us to create more
predictable workloads get a better
understanding of their customers get a
better understanding of the travels that
they're selling getting a better
understanding of their success so
getting the information you can imagine
they'll be able to even more efficiently
run their operations and last but not
least we're gonna build a customer
facing application using using flutter
the nice thing about flutter is for
those of you who don't know it's a it's
a way of writing or using one code base
and and write an application it will run
on both Android and iOS and it will
really help the customer to really have
that extended interaction with their
customers while the customers traveling
and since we can use as James explained
that native connection to the database
and still be sure that we have the full
security in there you can imagine that
it will make it will be a lot easier to
write those applications also because
flutter really nicely integrates with
the whole Phi base product because
firebase obviously has its roots in
mobile development and you can kind of
see where this is going so these are a
few very exciting updates that we're
going to do and it it's all updates that
will really fit the the development flow
that our developers have the work
in the the technical understandings that
they have so we're quite excited about
this definitely so it sounds like you
have a great set up here right you're
definitely improving the customer
experience and you know reducing their
workloads so uh well yeah it means that
because we have service as a new chef we
have service so we have more capacity as
we need it and for us it really means
that you know we don't need more
capacity it's the time for a vacation
right you need you've been hard at work
and once you ship these updates you can
schedule your own vacation of a lifetime
and not get charged six times for your
flight - that's true that's true yeah
well uh thank you
[Music]